AND WELCOME TO THE AUGUST
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. BEFORE WE
PROCEED IT LOOKS LET'S CALL THE
ROLL AND ESTABLISH A FORM
BERMAN HERE BERMAN HERE THEY
ARE TELL THEIR SEE OUR JOB HERE
THREE OF US. THREE OF US HERE
LOW. MAYES HERE MAYES HERE
MULLIN. BLANCA RUBIO HAVE A
QUORUM FANTASTIC THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU HAVE A QUORUM
TO THE COVER PANDEMIC WE
CONTINUE TO OPERATE WITH MODIFY
COMMITTEE PROCEDURES FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT AT THIS HEARING SOCIAL
DISTANCING IS REQUIRED IN THE
AUDIENCE OF THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM. ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS PRESENT IN THE HEARING
ROOM MUST WEAR A MASK OVER YOUR
MOUTH AND NOSE AT ALL TIMES WE
ALSO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE.
ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS MISTER
DOESN'T WORK. FOR THE PUBLIC TO
TESTIFY IN THE COMMITTEE
INCLUDING ALLOWING TESTIMONY
OUT OF REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
ON THE NORTH STEPS OF THE
CAPITOL AND ALONG TO SOME MONEY
BY PHONE. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF HEARING
AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC WITHIN
OUR TIME LIMITS WE WILL NOT
TOLERATE CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
COMMITTEE'S PROCEEDINGS.
DESTRUCTIBLE HITTER OR BEHAVIOR
THAT INCITES OR THREATENS
VIOLENCE INCLUDING VEILED
THREATS IS PROHIBITED. PLEASE
BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES MAYBES MAY SUBJECT
YOU TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS. THE
COMMITTEE IS TWO BILLS ON ITS
AGENDA TODAY. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
ABLE TO COMPLETE ITS BUSINESS
IN THE ALLOTTED TIME. WE'RE
LIMITING PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS
FOLLOWS FOR EACH BILL. THERE
WILL BE A MAXIMUM OF TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WITH A LIMIT OF TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS. AFTER WE
HEARD FROM THE PRIMARY WITNESS
THE PUBLIC WILL HAVE UP TO
THIRTY MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME.
FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
ON EACH BILL. STARTING WITH
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WERE HERE
IN THE ROOM. THESE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT IF
ANY IN A POSITION ON THE BILL.
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WILL BE
RULED OUT OF ORDER. IF YOU ARE
UNABLE TO GET THROUGH ON THE
PHONE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE PORTAL OF THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THIS
WRITTEN TESTIMONY WILL BECOME
PART OF THE OFFICIAL RECORD OF
THE BILL. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING THIS HEARING REMOTELY
INTO WHICH TO CALLING TO
REGISTER THEIR POSITION. THE
CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AGAIN THAT'S. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV OR COMPUTR SCREEN. IF
YOU WERE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST IN YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE- NINE ONE SIX. THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE FOUR IN
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY
TO HELP. THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO THE AGENDA I HAVE TO
ADDITIONAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TO
MAKE. FIRST ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS
RIVAS HAS BEEN APPOINTED TO THE
COMMITTEE TO REPLACE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STEVE BENNETT. FOR THE
ONLY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US SECOND THE COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN REQUESTED BY THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE TO PASS SB FIVE NINETY
FOUR AND DIRECTLY TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. SO THE MOTION
ON THE BILL TODAY WILL BE TO
PASS THE BILL TO THE FLOOR.
WITH ALMOST ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE
WAY WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA THE FIRST
ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS. AB FOR
SB FIVE NINETY FOUR BY CENTER
GLAZER THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER
FOR JOINING US TODAY YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL. THANK YOU AT
THAT WORK IN YEAH YEP THAT WAS
OKAY YEAH I THANK THE CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE ME FIRST
JUST THAT EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO- THE STAFF OF
YOUR COMMITTEE WELL AS MY STAFF
THAT WORKED ON THIS ISSUE OVER
THE LAST OF MANY MANY WEEKS AND
MONTHS AND I APPRECIATE IT VERY
MUCH- AS MANY OF YOU KNOW DUE
TO THE COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THE RELEASE OF CENSUS DATA WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED THE CYCLE
WHICH LED THE SUPREME COURT TO
MOVE BACK THE DEADLINE FOR
STATE AND CONGRESSIONAL
REDISTRICTING BY SEVERAL MONTHS
THE ORIGINAL DEADLINE. WAS
AUGUST FIFTEENTH OF THIS YEAR
THE NEW DEADLINE IS NOT FULLY
SETTLED. AND WILL LIKELY BE
CLARIFIED BY THE THROUGH THE
SUPREME COURT. BUT MOST LIKELY
BE SOMETIME BETWEEN LATE
DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR AND
EARLIER NAY JANUARY OF NEXT
YEAR AS A RESULT OF THIS
EXTENSION THE ELECTION CALENDAR
LEADING UP TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO PRIMARY. NEEDS TO BE
ADJUSTED TO RECONCILE THE
REDISTRICTING TIMELINE WITH THE
CANDIDATE FILING TIMELINE. AND
TO PROVIDE ELECTION OFFICIALS
WITH TIME TO RE PRECINCT THERE
AREA SB FIVE NINETY FOUR
ACCOMPLISHES THIS BY AMONG
OTHER ADJUSTMENTS SHORTENING
THE PERIOD FOR COLLECTING
SIGNATURES- IN LIEU OF PAYING A
FILING FEE. AND POTENTIALLY
ALSO SHORTENING THE TIME PERIOD
FOR FILING NOMINATION DOCUMENTS
DEPENDING ON HOW LATE THE
SUPREME COURT SETS THE STATE
REDISTRICTING DEADLINE TO
ACCOUNT FOR THIS ABBREVIATED
TIMELINE. THIS BILL REDUCES THE
NUMBER OF NECESSARY SIGNATURES
IN LIEU IN PROPORTION TO THE
REDUCTION IN TIME AND ALSO GETS
CANDIDATES FOR BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION THE STATE
LEGISLATURE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
ESTABLISH THE DISTRICT
RESIDENCY. AT THE TIME THEY
FILE RATHER THEN WHEN THEY PULL
THEIR NOMINATION PAPERS SB FIVE
NINETY FOUR ALSO MAKES A NUMBER
OF IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE
LOCAL REDISTRICTING PROCESS
INCLUDING. CORRECTING POTENTIAL
AMBIGUITIES IN STATE LAW THAT
MIGHT OTHERWISE REQUIRE LOCAL
MAPS TO BE APPROVED MORE THAN A
MONTH EARLIER THAN WAS INTENDED
AND CREATING A MORE UNIFORM
DEADLINE FOR SPECIAL DISTRICT
REDISTRICTING. THAT ALSO
ELIMINATES UNNECESSARILY EARLY
DEADLINE FOR CERTAIN SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THAT THESE CHANGES
PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENT WITH
MORE FLEXIBILITY AND TIME TO
DELIBERATE. WHILE PRESERVING
TIME FOR ELECTION OFFICIALS TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW LINES FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY ON
SB FIVE NINETY FOUR I HAVE WITH
ME SANTA CRUZ COUNTY REGISTRAR
TRICIA WEBER. WHO IS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS.
I KNOW THEY DON'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THIS BILL THAT MS
WEBER WILL SPEAK TO SOME
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THAT THE
ASSOCIATION CONSIDERS IMPORTANT
FOR ELECTION ADMINISTRATION
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER AND MS
WEBER- IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE BY
PHONE WE'RE READY WHENEVER YOU
ARE. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MORNING CARE BERMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND SENATOR
GLAZER. I'M TRICIA WEBER THE
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY CLERK
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS AND I'M
ALSO THE CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE I THANK
THE SENATOR GLAZER MENTIONED-
COMMITTEE IS NEITHER IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO S. B. FIVE
NINETY FOUR BUT WE ARE ASKED TO
SPEAK TO THE NECESSARY ASPECTS
OF THE BILL AND TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS EMAIL HAVE
AS YOU KNOW THE PANDEMIC CARSON
SYSTEM DATA DELAYS AND THOSE
DELAYS HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT ON
THE UPCOMING REDISTRICTING
PROCESS. ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
RECOGNIZE THAT CHANGES IN STATE
LAW ARE REQUIRED TO CONDUCT A
SUCCESSFUL PRIMARY ELECTION
NEXT YEAR. AND SB FIVE NINETY
FOUR HELPS THE SITUATION FIRST
OFF SB FIVE NINETY FOUR ALIGN
STATES FOR CERTAIN SPECIAL
DISTRICTS TO SUBMIT THEIR LINES
TO ELECTION OFFICIALS WHICH
WILL HELP ELECTION OFFICIALS
CREATE. A SYSTEM TO GET THEM
STARTED SO WHEN WE HAVE ALL OF
THE LINES WERE ABLE TO DO THE
REPRIEVE SINKING AND GET AND
SUBMIT THOSE NEW DISTRICT- NEW
PRECINCTS SB FIVE NINETY FOUR
ALSO ADDRESSES THE START DATE
FOR THE SIGNATURE IN LIEU
COLLECTION PERIOD WHICH IS THE
FIRST ACTIVITY CANDIDATES MAY
UNDERTAKE AND THEIR RUN FOR A
PRIMARY ELECTION OFFICE WITHOUT
A CHANGE IN STATE LAW THE
SIGNATURE IN THE PERIOD IS SET
TO START ON DECEMBER SIXTEENTH.
HOWEVER THE SOONEST NEW
CONGRESSIONAL AND STATE
LEGISLATIVE DISTRICT LINES WILL
BE FINALIZED IS DECEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTH. I THINK ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO ISSUE SIGNATURE ON
THE DOCUMENT TO PEOPLE WHOSE
DISTRICT ARE UNVEILED OR SOME
CANDIDATES WILL HAVE MORE TIME
TO COLLECT SIGNATURES THAN
OTHERS WHICH IS DISPARAGEMENT
THESE WINDS COULD POSSIBLY
FINALIZED AS LATE AS JANUARY
FOURTEENTH IF. THE BILL CAN
FEED THE CONVENTION REQUESTED
BY THE CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION IS GRANTED BY THE
SUPREME COURT SB FIVE NINETY
FOUR ADDRESSES THIS PROBLEM BY
SETTING THE DATE FOR SIGNATURE
IN THE COLLECTION TO BEGIN
SEVEN DAYS AFTER WHATEVER THE
STATE REDISTRICTING DEADLINE
ENDS UP BEING. BEST AVOIDING A
FIX DATE TIED TO THE JANUARY
FOURTEENTH WHICH COULD
ARTIFICIALLY TRUNCATE THIS
IMPORTANT PROCESS IF THE COURT
RULES FOR AN EARLIER DATE IN A
SIMILAR MANNER THIS BILL
CHANGES THE END DATE OF THE
SIGNATURE IN LIEU PERIOD AND
THE BEGINNING OF THE CANDIDATE
NOMINATION PERIOD FROM SIX
STATES SET BY CURRENT LAW. THE
FORTY ONE DAYS AFTER THE STATE
REDISTRICTING DEADLINE AND
FORTY SIX DAYS AFTER. THAT AND
FORTY SIX. DAYS RESPECTIVELY
KEEPING A TO FIND SEPARATE
PERIOD FOR THE TWO DIFFERENT
TASKS AND THAT'S DEFINITELY
PREFERRED BY THE ELECTION
OFFICIALS ADDITIONALLY FIVE
NINETY FOUR ESTABLISHES A
FORMULA TO BE USED TO
RECALCULATE THE VALUE OF EACH
SIGNATURE IN LIEU BECAUSE OF
THE SHORTENED COLLECTION
PERIOD. AND IT PLACES THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF CALCULATING
THOSE VALUES WITH THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE. BY PLACING
THIS RESPONSIBILITY WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE THERE WILL
BEA UNIFORM APPLICATION OF
THIS FORMULA ACROSS ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES. AND IF THE
WOMEN IT'S THE CONCERNS THAT
CANDIDATES MIGHT HAVE IF YOU
ARE MORE COUNTIES DISAGREED ON
HOW TO CALCULATE THE VALUE OF
THE SIGNATURE FINALLY THIS BILL
DOES NOT MOVE THE LAST STATE TO
COMPLETE CANDIDATE FILING WHICH
IS SET BY ALLIED EIGHTY EIGHT
DAYS BEFORE THE ELECTION. OR
EIGHTY THREE DAYS BEFORE IF AN
INCUMBENT FAILS TO FILE FOR
OFFICE. THIS IS A CRITICAL
FEATURE OF THE BILL AS AN
EXTENSION OF THE DEADLINE HAS A
MAJOR DOWNSTREAM OF FACT WITH
OTHER ELECTION DUTIES THAT
CANNOT BE SUFFICIENTLY MAPPED
OUT IF WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO
CONDUCT. OTHER ELECTIONS FOR
STILL DOING THE REDISTRICTING
WE REGISTERED ARE STILL
CONCERNED THAT WE WILL NOT HAVE
ENOUGH TIME TO ADEQUATELY INPUT
IMPROVE THE REDISTRICTING DATA
THAT WE MAKE IT AS LATE AS
JANUARY FOURTEENTH. HOWEVER SB
NINETY FOUR PROVIDES THE
FLEXIBILITY WITH THE EARLIEST
DEADLINES AND MAINTAINS THE
MOST CRUCIAL DEADLINES FOR
CANDIDATES FOR YOU FINALLY.
THANK YOU AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE THANK YOU MS WEBER-
AND WILL NOT MOVE ON A MISTER
MY A TO- THE PERMANENCE IN
OPPOSITION I GIVE MISS WEBER
FOUR MINUTES INSTEAD OF TWO
BECAUSE THERE IS ONLY ONE. FROM
MY WITNESS AND SUPPORT THERE'S
ONLY ONE PERSON ONE IS IN
OPPOSITION TO MR MADE IT. FEEL
FREE TO TAKE THE PERFORMANCE IF
YOU'D LIKE AND WE'RE READY WHEN
YOU ARE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD ON THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AFFECTING
VOTING RIGHTS MY NAME IS DANIEL
MY AT A CO CHAIR OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION. IT'S
THE FIRST BODY IN HISTORY
TASKED WITH DRAWING NEW
SUPERMAJORITY WILL DISTRICTS IN
L. A. COUNTY COMPLETELY
INDEPENDENT OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. YOU DO THIS TASK
WE MUST WE HAVE TO EVALUATE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS DATA TAKE
PUBLIC INPUT TO ALL FIVE
DISTRICTS WITH THE SAME
POPULATION THAT EITHER FAVOR
VOTER SCREAMING EIGHT AGAINST
POLITICAL PARTIES OR
INCUMBENTS. THAT WE COMPLY WITH
THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT AND THAT
SURVIVOR SERIES OF WHAT THE
SUSPECTED TO BE ROCKED THIS
PUBLIC HEARINGS. AND TO DO ALL
OF THIS NO LATER THAN OUR
STATUTORY MAP ADOPTION DEADLINE
OF DECEMBER FIFTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IT WAS ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE BUT THE DELAY OF THE
CENSUS DATA MAKES THIS TASK
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT THE
CALIFORNIA CRC IS ASKING THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
BURNING SCANSION OF ITS
DEADLINE OF JANUARY FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. HOUR
DEADLINE HOWEVER IS STATUTORY
THAT'S WHY WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
AMANDA S. B. FIVE NINETY FOUR
TO EXTEND OUR MAP ADOPTION
DEADLINE TO THE SAME DATE
JANUARY. FOURTEENTH OF TWENTY
TWO. WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
SAME INDEPENDENT COMMISSION SIX
THE SAME EXTENT STATUS THIRTY
DAYS MOBILE NAVAL ARE
CONDITIONS TO MORE THOROUGHLY
ANALYZED THE DATA. AND ENSURE
THAT THE NEW DISTRICTS PROTECT
EVERYONE'S VOTING RIGHTS. IT
ALSO GIVES THE COMMUNITY A
GREATER OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH
IN. THE RESULTS WILL BE A
BETTER FINAL MAP THAT HAS MORE
PUBLIC BY FINALLY THE CURRENT
STILL AMENDS AMPLE PROVISION
THAT SAYS THAT ALL COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS MUST DRAW NEW
DISTRICT MAPS EVERY DECADE. BUT
THESE CHANGES DID NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE THE BOWL OF
INDEPENDENCE DISTRICTING
COMMISSIONS LIKE THOSE IN LA
AND SAN DIEGO COUNTIES. WE URGE
THAT SECTION TWO OF THE BILL BE
CLARIFIED BY NOTING IN SECTION
TWENTY ONE FIVE HUNDRED PER AND
A CLOSE. ABOUT ELECTIONS CODE
THAT A COUNTY BOARD SAID OPTION
OF A MAP IS ONLY APPLICABLE
WHAT THE COUNTY HAS NO
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION ESTABLISHED BY STATE
LAW. WITH THOSE TWO AMENDMENTS
THE L. A. COUNTY CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION CAN
AND WILL. SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU VERY MR
MIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
NINETY FOUR AS A REMINDER WE
WILL HAVE A MAXIMUM OF THIRTY
MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED RIGHT IN THE NAME OF
THE ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT
IF ANY AND THEIR POSITION ON
THE BILL WILL START THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
PROVIDE A POSITION ON SB FIVE
NINETY FOUR. SEEING NONE OTHER
ANY WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION TO PROVIDE
THE POSITION ON SB FIVE NINETY
FOUR. SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE THE POSITION ON SB
FIVE NINETY FOUR MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU
MEDICARE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT. OF SB
FIVE NINETY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND PUSH BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. SB.
FIVE NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW THE MESSAGE HERE
WE DO HAVE PARTICIPANTS QUEUING
UP. LINE NUMBER SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIRTY CAD ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH SO I THINK THAT
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE IN POSITION
ON THE BILL YEAH. THANK YOU
FOR- HEARING- YOUR WORK YOU'RE
DOING ITS A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
TO BE DOING STUFF LIKE CHANGING
THAT CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE SO- I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU GUYS-
CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT
NOBODY IS INVOLVED IN THIS AND
YOU'RE GOING TO CHANGE THE
WHOLE STRUCTURE. THE PROVIDE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION YOU'RE-
IN POSITION ON THE BILL AND-
YES ON THE- NOT IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL MY NAME IS FUNKY FATHER
AND THE- FATHER SAYS NO TO THIS
THANK YOU FOR CALLING HOME ALL
THIS MOVE ON OPERATOR TO THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU
LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING CARE MEMBERS JULIE HALL
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES AND COURTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH LINE
NUMBER ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING
CHECKING OVER THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JEAN HURTS CALLING IN TODAY IN
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LINE NUMBER FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING PAUL YODER ON BEHALF OF
THE PLEASURE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LINE NUMBER
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TERM
MEMBERS ANTHONY CAMECO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION I'M ALI DIDN'T
STILL HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
MOVING THE ADOPTION DATE
FORWARD. FOR SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS. ARE WE DO APPRECIATE
THE BREEDING GROUND FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS IN NOVEMBER ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE MAP AND
OPTION DATE AND SO ON THAT ARE
THE MEASURE SUPPORTABLE AND I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR ALL
OF THEIR ENGAGEMENT. ARTWORK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AT THIS
TIME ATTENTION WE HAVE NO ELSE
THANK YOU GREAT THE WITH THAT
WILL MOVE IT ON TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMITTEES MOTIONS SECONDS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. GOT
MOTION GOT A SECOND DOES ANY
QUESTIONS CENTER GLAZER WE LEAD
CLOSE. I THANK EACH YEAR
BERMAN- A COUPLE THINGS IN
RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU HEARD THAT
THIS MORNING- FIRST THE I THE
CONCERNED BY THE L. A. I.
COMMISSION AND I'D ALSO IT I'VE
HEARD THAT THE CSU COULD
COMMISSION THAT. THAT A
PROVISION AUTHORIZING COUNTY
REDISTRICTING BY RESOLUTION
MIGHT SOMEHOW UNDO THE
AUTHORITY OF THE COMMISSION TO
DRAW LINES. I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT- SB FIVE NINETY FOUR NO
WAY ELIMINATES THEIR
INDEPENDENT COMMISSION WORK OR
GIVE THEIR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THE ABILITY TO OVERTURN THE
WORK OF THEIR COMMISSION- WE
DON'T TOUCH ANY OF THE
PROVISIONS RELATING TO THAT IN
THIS BILL. I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S- LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT WOULD SUPPORT THAT CONCERN
BUT I'M HAPPY TO MAKE IT CLEAR
IN THE LEGISLATIVE HISTORY-
THAT WE DON'T- AFFECT ANY OF
THE ANYTHING THAT RELATED TO
THAT CONCERN. AND SECONDLY. THE
ISSUE OF TIME AND THE EXTENSION
OF TIME WE ALL WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE MORE TIME IN THIS PROCESS
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S BEEN
THINGS THAT OUT OF OUR CONTROL
THEY'VE KIND OF PUT US IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE WHICH JUSTIFIES
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL I WOULD
NOTE THAT. THAT OUR STATE
COMMISSION HAS TO DRAW LINES
FOR A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
DISTRICTS AND THESE COUNTIES
THAT HAVE RAISED CONCERNS I
HAVE TO DROP FIVE. SOURCE IN
SOME CASES SEVEN BUT MUCH FEWER
SO I'M SENSITIVE TO THAT THEIR
IMPORTANT WORK THAT THEY'RE
UNDERTAKING TO MR MYATA THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND YOUR
YOUR YOUR COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMISSION FOR THEIR SERVICE.
WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT AND
WE'RE SORRY THE CIRCUMSTANCES
KIND OF UP PROVIDE THAT THAT
THE SHORTENING OF TIME THAT WE
WOULD ALL WHICH WASN'T THERE
BUT WITH THAT MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS VERY YOU AND
YOUR STAFF AND MY STAFF- FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS VERY
COMPLICATED- ISSUE THAT THAT WE
WISH WE DIDN'T HAVE TO DEAL
WITH BUT BUT WE ARE IN THE
PLACE THAT WE ARE AND DIFFERENT
FOLLOW UP. AND SECOND YEAR
THANKS TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE CITIZEN COMMISSIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE VOLUNTEERING
THEIR TIME- TO IT TO HELP TRY
TO MAKE OUR DISTRICTS REALLY
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY LIVE IN-
I WHICH I THINK IS SUCH
IMPORTANT WORK. THE DELAYS IN
THE RELEASE OF DATA FROM THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS OF PUSH
BACK THE REDISTRICTING PROCESS
LIKE YOU SAID CENTER AND
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS STILL
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE STATE
REDISTRICTING DEADLINE.
NONETHELESS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION WINDING
DOWN WE NEED TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS NOW TO THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE REDISTRICTING
PROCESS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO ELECTION CALENDAR TO
ACCOMMODATE A LATER DEADLINE.
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL SEEKS
TO BALANCE SEVERAL FACTORS
INCLUDING ENSURING THAT
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS OF
SUFFICIENT TIME TO PREPARE FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO PRIMARY
ELECTION. SO ON NOBODY GOT
EVERYTHING THAT THEY WANTED IN
THIS BILL- I APPRECIATE THE
COMPROMISES THAT NEED TO BE
MADE UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES
AND I'M HAPPY TO RECOMMEND
SUPPORT WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS DUE CAST BERMAN
HI BERMAN I FAIR TO SAY ARE TO
LOSE RIVAS. THREE OF US. I LOW
HELLO I MAYES MAYES I MULLIN
MOREOVER I WANT RUBIO BLANCA
RUBIO I THANK YOU CENTER THE
BILLS OUT STATE SEVEN IN THE
SEVEN MODES THE NEXT ON THE
AGENDA IS AB FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY SOME NUMBER THREE OF US
THANKS SO MUCH- PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY GOT
MOTION GOT A SECOND GOT A
SECOND ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THE
GREAT BILL FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH
YES YES LEARNING. SHERIN
MEMBERS- AS YOU MAY KNOW THE
COMMITTEE ALREADY HEARD AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE EARLIER
THIS YEAR I'M THE EARLIER
VERSION OF AB FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA LAW IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE SEVENTEENTH AMENDMENT
OF THE U. S. CONSTITUTION BY
PROVIDING FOR AN ELECTION TO BE
HELD TO FILL A VACANCY AND
CALIFORNIA'S. REPRESENTATION IN
THE U. S. SENATE EVEN IF THE
VACANCY OCCURS DURING THE LAST
TWO YEARS OF THE U. S. SENATE
TERM THE BILL THIS VERSION OF
THE BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE- AND WHAT THE BILL DOES
NOW IN ADDITION TO IT
PREVIOUSLY DID. OF L. A. COUNTY
IS CURRENTLY PILOTING A PROJECT
USING AN ALTERNATE BALLOT ORDER
WHERE LOCAL OFFICES APPEAR ON
THE BALLOT BEFORE STATE AND
FEDERAL OFFICES. IT'S UNCLEAR
HOW THIS WOULD IMPACT
PARTICIPATION WHEN A SPECIAL
VACANCY ELECTION AND REELECTION
WOULD APPEAR ON THE SAME BALLOT
BUT IN DIFFERENT LOCATIONS ON
THE BALLOT. AB FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE WILL ENSURE THAT WHEN THE
SPECIAL VACANCY ELECTION AND A
REGULAR ELECTION FOR THE SAME
LEGISLATIVE OR CONGRESSIONAL
SEAT APPEAR ON THE SAME BALLOT
THAT VOTERS WILL BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY AND UNDERSTAND THIS BY
PLACING THE TWO ELECTIONS AT
THE FRONT OF THE BALLOT WITH
CLEARLY MARKED HEADERS. THIS
HELPS ELIMINATE VOTER CONFUSION
ENSURES GREATER PARTICIPATION
OF VOTERS AND HELPS REDUCE
ELECTION COSTS THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS. AND I'D NEXT WE'LL MOVE
ON A PRIOR WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE
ANY PRIMER WITNESSES AND EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- SO WE
WILL. NOW MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE. AS A REMINDER WE
WILL HAVE A MAXIMUM OF THIRTY
MINUTES IN TOTAL TIME FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT. ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
LIMITED TO WRITING THEIR NAME
THE ORGANIZATION OF THE
REPRESENT IF ANY AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL. WILL STAR
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO PROVIDE THE POSITION ON AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE. SEEING
NONE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES AT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION A
BROTHER POSITION ON AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE. SEEING NONE WE
WILL NOW OPEN THE PHONE LNES
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO PROVIDE THE POSITION ON
AB FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
DAY BE FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE.
GIVEN THE CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACED
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AB FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE THIS PRESS ONE THAN THEIR
OWN NOW. LINE NUMBER TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MANY CALIFORNIANS OFF ON
THE LAST BILL AND YOU DIDN'T
GIVE PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IF I DIDN'T KNOW BETTER
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR NAME MINE
IS A SINGER WITH THE IMPOSITION
ON THE BILL LET ME REPEAT YOU
CUT OFF QUITE A FEW PLEASE MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT. CALLER NUMBER.
NINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX YOUR%
LINE IS OPEN MY NUMBER TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD WHY NUMBER TWENTY SIX
ISN'T IT FUNNY HOW I'M GETTING
MY ONE ON THE NEXT LINE THE
BILL LINE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YES THIS IS LIBERTY AIMS
HELLO AB ONE FOUR NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE MOMENT
AT A WOULD YOU HAVE SOMEONE TO
IN THAT BAD DURING THEIR LINE
NUMBER NOW. BERMAN GATHERING
THE LINE NUMBER MESSAGER THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH I CAN THINK ON THE
OTHER BILLS IT'S CONFUSING I
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU GUYS DO
SOME SYSTEM IS HERE. TO ANSWER
THAT I CAN'T SPEAK TO WHEN YOU
LINED UP- BUT- HAPPY TO TAKE
YOUR TESTIMONY NOW YOU CAN ALSO
SUBMIT TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHICH WOULD
BE PART OF A PUBLIC RECORD. BUT
IF YOU'D LIKE TO STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH
AND POSITION ON AYE EITHER AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE OR AB OR
SB FIVE NINETY FOUR PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO RIGHT NOW NOW IF GAZA
SYSTEM. OKAY OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THE HOW TO RESPOND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE LEXUS- NEXT CALLER
THE LINE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD AS I SAID YOU HAVE KERR
CALIFORNIANS OFTEN WOULD LIKE
TO OFFER A BIGGER NAME
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH AND
POSITION ON THE BILL EITHER
BILL AB FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE OR
SB FIVE NINETY FOUR. THE TIME
IS THAT HERE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE WILL MOVE ON TO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE HAVE A
MOTION WITH THE SECOND OTHER
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING NONE. AS A MEMBER RIVAS
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
APPLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING OVER THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. HELPING TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA LAWS CONSISTENT WITH
THE U. S. CONSTITUTION. THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS SHOULD HELP
AVOID VOTER CONFUSION IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WERE PROBABLY
PROJECT IS TESTING THE EFFECTS
OF A NOVEL BALLOT ORDER. I'M
HAPPY TO RECOMMEND SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL- I'M CENTER PLEASE
CALL VOTE. THE MOTION IS WITH
RECOMMENDATION THAT SEVEN
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
BERMAN HI. BERMAN I FIGURE
TELCO SAY ARE TOO LOW
THREE OF US HI THIS RIVAS I
HELLO. LOW MAYES. MAYES MULLIN.
MULLIN I BLANCA RUBIO. BLANCA
RUBIO I. SIX TO ONE THAT BUILDS
ON THE SIX TO. SHE'S BEEN THAT
BILLS ON SIX ONE VOTE THANK YOU
SOMEONE MEMBER RIVAS AND I
BELIEVE EVERYBODY'S VOTED ON
ALL BILLS SO THAT THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED THE HEARING TO
TURN.